what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and as we mentioned in our video
yesterday it looks like we could be
getting a new Avengers team in the MCU
however I'm not talking about a team
that is going to appear in The Avengers
film The Kang Dynasty or the next
Avengers film Avengers Secret Wars we
are talking about another Avengers film
that could be coming before both of
these movies and it looks like it could
be coming in quite an interesting way
and it looks like it could also have an
extremely interesting plot as well it
actually involves the return of Ultron
and if everything pans out the way that
some of these reports State they will it
actually makes a ton of sense and I
really hope that this is what they
decide to do in the path that they go
down now the new Avengers film would
involve quite a bit of change and it
would be a different Avengers team the
roster would be different than what we'd
see in Avengers the King Dynasty and
Secret Wars you see this new Avengers
film is going to be our armor Wars with
Roadie AKA War Machine recent reports
that we'll get into state that this
movie is actually going to be a new
Avengers movie and that it is
specifically going to be the West Coast
Avengers and it sounds like it's going
to bring some great characters together
with Roadie being the team leader now
many of you have probably heard that
armor Wars is kind of undergoing some
changes in fact the biggest change
that's been made to it so far is that it
originally started off as a Disney plus
series but is now a full featured film
it's a movie and now this movie could be
about a new Avengers team the West Coast
Avengers so how did this exactly happen
let's talk about this before we dive
into the reported plot the first thing
that you need to know is that it
actually might get a name change this
was reported by the account sinistelth
who has been very accurate with their
reports over the years on January 9th a
few days ago they tweeted armor Wars
might get a title change now the same
time that this report came out the same
day on January February 9th another
account great phase came out and
reported that armor Wars is going to be
a West Coast Avengers movie so if the
title gets changed it's probably going
to get changed to something involving
the West Coast Avengers it could even
Simply Be West Coast Avengers now some
people might be worried that Roadie
might not get all the spotlight after
all this was supposed to be his show and
then his movie but based off of these
reports that we've gotten it does still
seem like it is going to be about him
and Don Cheadle has even spoken up
recently about a little bit of what to
expect from the film specifically
talking about rhody's journey and the
plot of this movie is going to start off
in secret Invasion Don Cheadle has
confirmed this and it does make a lot of
sense it makes sense not only with the
continuity of the MCU and roady's
character but also with the plot of what
armor Wars slash the West Coast Avengers
film would be about but as far as this
movie focusing on Don Cheadle this is
what he had to say in a recent interview
with total film I don't think we've ever
really dug into him and now it's an
opportunity to really explore his
emotional life his interior life his
relationships his trajectory where he
wants to go what his challenges are and
this interview was only a couple of days
ago so if they've been making changes it
seems to be very apparent that this
movie is still going to be all about
Roadie and in this interview he did say
that the storyline for this movie is
going to somewhat follow the storyline
from the actual Comics he said obviously
you have to play off the Marvel stuff
and be in the lore of the mythology of
the character and the MCU in general but
trying to build out this character and
make him a three-dimensional dude is
what the goal is so I'm excited about
that so it is going to focus on him
regardless of what the name of the
project is going to be but let's talk
about the reported plot because it
actually ties in perfectly with who
James Rhodes is not only did this report
state that armor Wars could be turning
into a West Coast Avengers movie it also
stated that Ultron will return it also
talks about the Raw roster but we'll
talk about that in just a bit the fact
that Ultron could return in armor Wars
is fantastic and super exciting but most
importantly it makes sense armor Wars is
supposed to be about what happens when
Tony Stark's Iron Man Tech gets into the
wrong hands what happens when Iron Man
Tech is used for evil not good well
here's the thing about that Ultron is
Iron Man Tech and they made it very
clear in Avengers Age of Ultron Tony
Stark said that every trace of Ultron
had to be destroyed or he could come
back because he could still exist out
there on the web and if he did he could
return well we've already kind of seen
many hints of him still existing in
Spider-Man homecoming we saw the head of
an Ultron bot plus not to mention sword
created another Vision but they did that
without an infinity stone which is where
Vision kind of came from without it he
is basically still just Ultron so it
definitely seems like traces of Ultron
are still out there plus not to mention
other outlets have reported that Ultron
is going to be turning as well
thecosmiccircus.com being one of them
they stated that they've heard from
their sources Ultron will indeed be
returning and War machine's movie is
perfect for that because as Don Cheadle
stated this is going to be about him and
his personal journey and his
relationships well we know that Iron Man
Tony Stark was his best friend he also
had a major role to play in Avengers Age
of Ultron he watched Tony Stark create
Ultron and then he helped him clean up
the mess so this is unfinished business
with him and his old best friend who I'm
sure we're going to see him mourn over
in this movie so it's going to be
extremely personal roady's not going to
want his best friend's Tech in the wrong
hands so people could remember him the
wrong way not that they really should
after all Tony Stark did sacrifice
himself to save the entire universe but
you know roady's going to look out for
Tony Stark even after he's gone plus you
know the whole world is kind of a
Jeopardy and and danger of Ultron
returns and Roadie is in the military it
kind of goes along with his job so as
far as the plot of this is concerned I
think it makes a lot of sense however
there is another aspect to the plot that
I think we need to address and that is
the possibility of Scrolls playing a
part of this movie Don Cheadle has
already confirmed that he is going to be
in secret Invasion we know what secret
invasion is going to be about it's about
Scrolls infiltrating Earth specifically
very important organizations and heck as
far as we know some scroll have
impersonated some Avengers possibly even
Tony Stark to go into Tony Stark's lab
and take some of his stuff we know a lot
is going to be revealed in secret
Invasion and in that same interview with
total film Don Cheadle said this I'm in
secret Invasion so I'm in Sam Jackson's
show there's a part of that that kicks
off what happens in armor Wars well
again secret invasion is going to be
about the scroll infiltrating important
and kind of dangerous organizations so
since these events kick off the things
that are going to happen in armor Wars
I'm assuming that some scroll have their
hands on some Iron Man Tech and some of
that could be Ultron related and if
that's the case honest honestly it
sounds pretty dang amazing now the rest
of this report talking about how armor
Wars could be a West Coast Avengers film
States the expected roster says Roadie
Vision ironheart Wonder Man as well as
Kate bishop and potentially Shang Chi
now Vision kind of just makes sense if
they're going after Ultron vision is the
one who helped take him down before so
it just makes sense to have him join the
fight again however this won't be the
same vision at least as far as we know
this will most likely be spectral Vision
the one that sword created that we were
introduced to in one division at the
very end of one division he sort of just
took off and that's the last we've heard
of him but of course we know marvel has
plans for him and it looks like it could
be for this movie now since ironheart
basically is an Iron Man suit it makes
sense to have her in this movie as well
what better way to fight Iron Man Tech
than with Iron Man Tech slash wakandan
Tech now we know that Wonder Man is
getting his own Disney plus series and
it's good to know that Marvel Studios
could be thinking about including him in
more than just a series but an actual
West Coast Avengers film especially when
he has ties with vision in fact in the
comics Vision was designed with the
memories of Wonder Man in fact wonder
man had feelings for the Scarlet Witch
and some say that this is the reason
that Vision actually had feelings for
the Scarlet Witch because he had the
memories of Wonder Man so that
connectivity is certainly going to be
something that I would love to see play
out in the MCU and the fact that Kate
bishop and potentially could show up in
this roster is also extremely exciting
so we'll see if these reports come true
we do know armor Wars is indeed going
through some changes so it looks like we
could be getting a West Coast Avengers
movie if this happens let me know what
you think about it in the comments down
below are you excited and what would you
like to see don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof
foreign